CNN chief Jeff Zucker gets caught on
camera telling his journalists to stop
associating with Republicans and to
start pushing impeachment the mainstream
media lose their collective minds over a
meme depicting violence against
journalists while they ignore real world
of violence against conservatives and
then a story you certainly will not hear
about in the mainstream media
transgender regret we speak with Peter
Benjamin who had the transgender surgery
lived as a woman came to regret it is
now identifying again as a male and has
some serious warnings about the spread
of transgender ideology throughout the
culture we will get to all of that I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
breaking news CNN is a bunch of
dishonest tax I know that's not exactly
a Man Bites Dog story that's more of a
dog bites man's story because we already
knew that from the very beginning but
now we have audio confirmation of this
because an actual journalist James
O'Keefe went in there went into CNN
and was able to catch on bits of
information from sources and from audio
and from phone calls where CNN chief
Jeff Zucker actually admits that he is
using his alleged news network to push
for the partisan political goal of
impeaching President Trump my name is
Kerry porch I am a satellite uplink
technician I'm a contractor at the CNN
Washington DC bureau
basically I decided to wear a hidden
camera I decided to secretly record the
9:00 a.m. rundown call meetings and it's
basically run by Jeff Zucker the
president of CNN when I came to work at
CNN I mean it was my dream job and that
dream actually just turned into a
nightmare okay so the very first voice
you heard that is Jeff Zucker then he
goes in and the source talks to media
coordinators floor directors various
people at CNN who were all backing up
what we just heard from Jeff Zucker
which is Jeff Zucker has a personal
vendetta against Trump he is directing
the network's news coverage to focus on
and to actually push impeachment
now look news outlets can have their own
editorial positions it's a little
dishonest of CNN because CNN pretends to
only be facts first and they're not
admitting that their news programming is
really opinion programming but okay that
that's all even sort of understandable
the footage gets even more specific
though because you then hear Jeff Zucker
telling his team to stop paddling around
with prominent Republicans why because
they're not objective journalists
covering the news they are partisans
pushing a narrative for the left and for
the Democratic Party
is really fundamentally okay so he says
I know a lot of you guys are friendly
with Lindsey Graham cut that out time to
knock that off no more being friends
with Lindsey Graham we need to go after
Lindsey Graham every single Republican
we need to go after and then he has the
audacity and the gist obliviousness the
unselfish to say this is a result of
years and years of fake news from Fox
which is the more conservative Network
not years and years of fake news from us
even though on this call I am admitting
we are fake news we are not a news
network we are partisans pushing a
partisan political objective on behalf
of Democrats it's Fox News's fault say
whatever you want about Fox News you're
Jeff Zucker you're CNN you're the guy
doing this right now how about some
self-awareness they can't muster it and
you see this in a lot of major fake news
stories from accusing the president of
violence when it's the left calling for
violence themselves to absolutely
abhorrent fake news over Syria and the
Turkish invasion of Syria all the way
down we'll get to that in a second but
first I've got to tell you how much I
love movement you know that I love
movement
I love movement watches I love their
products well now movement has something
that is so incredibly useful for
probably 60 to 70 percent of your day
and that is when you're staring at a
screen how much time you spend in front
of a screen if you are like most people
you wake up first thing you do is you
look at a screen then you go to your
computer and you look at a screen and
you read the news then you go to work
and you're on a screen all day then you
you're on your phone whenever you're not
looking at the screen on your computer
you're looking down at the screen on
your phone then you come home you watch
a screen until you go to bed and then
you're scrolling in bed on a screen and
then you try to go to bed that's too
much movements ever scroll blue light
filtering glasses will protect your eyes
from the blue light that is known to
cause eye strain discomfort
and poor sleeping patterns I now pretty
much don't look at a screen without
protecting my eyes from blue light
because lool I just kind of keeps you up
it keeps you a little bit more agitated
the average person spends almost seven
hours a day in front of a screen
movements blue light glasses help to
change our habits so that we can keep up
with a changing technological world ever
scroll blue light filtering glasses
start at just 65 bucks and let me tell
you you are just gonna feel better and
more relaxed and you get to sleep easier
that's been my experience at least
whether you're at the office or you
scrolling through your phone or you're
unwinding from a long day just watching
an episode or two ever scroll glasses
have you covered better focus better
sleep and better style this is the thing
about movement I always get compliments
on movement no matter what product it is
that I'm wearing because they just look
so cool that could be their watches
their sunglasses or their ever scroll
glasses today you can get 15% off with
free shipping and free returns by going
to MVM t.com slash knowles canada wles
shop movement ever scroll blue light
filtering glasses protect your eyes and
most importantly in this culture of ours
look great doing it MVM t.com / knowles
KO wles
joined the movement so there CNN is is
more or less admitting I mean we've now
heard it on tape that they're pushing
impeachment they don't want their hosts
to pal around with Lindsey Graham but
it's not just CNN I don't want to only
beat up on CNN the whole mainstream
media are like this CNN just got caught
doing it CNN got a little too sloppy
shel this is a big story that came out
yesterday big huge story now it doesn't
it's not a big event it's not an event
that really matters at all but the story
in the mainstream media was so big
according to the mainstream media if you
were reading the news yesterday Twitter
President Trump
participated in a video that showed him
murdering members of the mainstream
media with a gun with a pistol flipping
him over shooting them killing him as a
trump video of violent Trump video and
Trump has to apologize this according to
the mainstream media CNN or rather NBC's
so hard there's a basic
all the same network so it's hard to
keep them straight NBC's Lester Holt has
the story tonight the White House is
trying to distance the president from a
disturbing video showing a likeness of
him violently attacking his political
opponents and the news media it was
apparently played at a conference at one
of the president's Florida resorts
Hallie Jackson has that story they're
trying to distance the White House
trying to distance President Trump from
a violent disturbing video and they
obviously would only have to distance
him if President Trump had something to
do with the video which of course we
here at NBC are going to insinuate even
though that isn't true at all there's no
evidence of that whatsoever and it has
no basis in reality what's the actual
video the actual video is a meme it's a
meme it's an internet meme where it's a
scene from the 2014 movie the Kingsmen
and it's a scene in which a guy walks in
and shoots up a whole church and the guy
walking in in this scene is President
Trump they have like Trump's face kind
of pasted it on the guy and then on all
the people in the congregation they have
different outlets different news outlets
not so many people I mean one or two but
it's mostly you know like the CNBC logo
or the ABC logo or the Politico logo and
Trump walks in and just commits acts of
violence on every single one of these
outlets here's just a little taste
[Applause]
his arms and throwing cage for
pedophiles and let them have
[Music]
[Music]
okay it goes on goes on like that for a
while and then Trump just blows up the
whole whole group of mainstream media
people it's a meme it looks like a meme
it's obviously very poor quality cuz
it's just still images pasted onto
moving bodies but that's it that's it
but so the real headline is somebody
made a meme and then and then what
actually happened was at a pro Trump
conference not organized by Trump not
really that closely affiliated with
Trump but an organization that supports
Trump American priority had a conference
and it was played there now wasn't
played on the big screen it wasn't the
center of the conference this conference
had a contest for memes this so they put
out a call for memes people submitted
their memes this was one of the memes
and it was shown in a side room and a
small TV with not that many people
watching or probably I don't know 10 or
15 people watching in the room and then
and then it became a big news story
because the mainstream media saw it and
they played it for millions of people
now the meme as I said comes from this
2014 movie the Kingsmen what there is a
little irony here in that there was no
outrage whatsoever when the movie came
out and the movie depicted a guy
shooting up an entire church full of
people that no outrage but a meme that
very few people saw of Trump shooting
logos of NBC that that was the end of
the world the event organizers totally
disavowed the video they said the video
is not approved scener sanctioned a MPF
fest condemns all violence in the
strongest terms and only wants to unite
americans so what do I think of the meme
I don't really care I mean it's I guess
it's a funny meme and that memes are
funny and they're they're disrespectful
and you know that's what they are if
President Trump had tweeted this out I
would say that's a very bad thing if
some really prominent person in Trump's
orbit tweeted this out I would say
that's a really really bad thing you
don't want that sort of stuff out there
you don't want to incite violence
against Americans of course you couldn't
say this is unprecedented in our
political rhetoric I mean let's not
forget when we think back of the halcyon
days of our republic in the early
founding days say for instance 1804 when
the sitting vice president literally
murdered
the former Treasury secretary with a
real pistol in a real duel you know
there are there is some precedent for
these kind of things if if I have to
choose between Aaron Burr the sitting
vice president killing Alexander
Hamilton or some guy making a meme I'm
certainly going to take some guy making
a meme but okay it's not good the
organizer apologizes fine good enough
the White House even condemned it the
White House said we haven't seen the
meme but we've heard it's no good so
okay we condemn it but that's not good
enough for the mainstream media here's
Brooke Baldwin on CNN mr. president why
is it taking you so long
to condemn this video you tweet all the
time I don't want to hear from your
press secretary who says you strongly
condemn the video I want to hear from
you the video I'm referring to is
obtained by the New York Times
it is extremely violent it is disturbing
and cNN has confirmed it was shown at a
pro Trump political conference and in
case you have not seen it it depicts a
killing spree inside of a church a scene
cut from a 2014 film okay excuse me just
once I just need to take one quick break
to give me a break
I love this she goes when is the
president going to condemn this hey
Brooke uh he already condemned it well
yeah but he only condemned it through
his spokesman and I don't want to hear
it from his spokesman who speaks for him
I I want it I want him to do it I want I
I want what I want I want President
Trump to take responsibility for
something that he had nothing to do with
whatsoever
that he's already condemned through a
spokesman okay that's fine
meanwhile meanwhile so that's a meet
like here's the story a guy made a me
meanwhile outside of a Trump rally in
Minneapolis some leftist thug smacked a
woman in the face because she was
walking with a guy who was wearing a
make America great again sweatshirt
[Applause]
yes so that actual violence against
conservatives against against a woman -
no reporting you're not gonna see that
on the mainstream media oh but hey
Michael that was just one event right
that was just one fringy moment where
some random person smacked somebody come
on that doesn't seem like it's part of a
pattern of leftist violence except for
all of the open public calls for leftist
violence against conservatives from
Hollywood from politicians and from you
guessed it the news media yes a lot
about blowing up the White House knew
details today on the incident that left
Senator Rand Paul with six broken ribs
this might be one of my favorite stories
although of course we don't want a
clearly Senator Paul's still struggling
prison Walker how do you resist the
temptation to run up and wring her neck
you cannot be civil with a political
party that wants to destroy what you
stand for what you care about that's why
I believe if we are fortunate enough to
win back the house and/or the Senate
that's when civility can start again but
I'd like I like that you're all a part
of it when was the last time an actor
assassinated the president okay well
but a meme a guy made a meme and it was
shown in a little room somewhere so that
so Trump needs to condemn that Brooke
Baldwin I want to hear from you I don't
want to hear from well actually I don't
as far as I can tell nobody on the left
has apologized for these open calls for
violence or the violence itself but I
want to hear from you Brooke Baldwin not
from one of your spokesmen I want you to
condemn this kind of violence that calls
for violence from the politicians from
the celebrities and from the mainstream
media I think something tells me we'll
be waiting a long
time for that that is that is the
anatomy of a fake news story Trump needs
to distance himself from a disturbing
video Trump needs to apologize for
something he has nothing to do with
meanwhile the left actually calling for
violence actually committing violence at
the highest and most public levels no
accountability at all not whatsoever
okay that's fine
speaking of violence and speaking of
fake news ABC News just caught got
caught in a huge fake news story so
you've seen a lot of the coverage in
Syria the United States moved some
troops from northern Syria 50 to 150
special operators this was condemned
widely by people in the Pentagon and in
the national security establishment and
the more interventionist Republicans and
the convenient left the let you know the
left would have been thrilled if Obama
had done this but now they're pretending
the Hajduk has trumped it and the
controversy was that we were leaving our
Kurdish allies to basically meet a lot
of gunfire from the invading Turkish
forces but my big strong hardline take
on Syria was hey close your eyes and
pick out Syria on a maps you know where
it is hey close your eyes and can you
name any of the countries around Syria
okay I'll give you one Turkey can your
name where Turkey is around Syria no
probably not the situation is much much
more complicated than both sides are
pretending that it is and so that's my
that's my big strong take the mainstream
media though obviously taking the side
against President Trump here they played
a video on ABC of the crisis in Syria so
it says new developments crisis in Syria
Isis prisoners escaped as death toll
rises and they run a report of this
really horrific looking footage
allegedly showing the Kurds being
shelled like Hellfire raining down from
heaven by the Turkish forces here's the
report there's just one little problem
with the report but here's the report
this video obtained by ABC News appears
to show the fury of the Turkish attack
on the
go to town Nutella via a border town
bombarded by turkeys military this video
right here appearing to show turkeys
military bombing curve civilians in a
Syrian border town the Kurds who fought
alongside the u.s. against Isis now
horrific reports of atrocities committed
by Turkish back fighters on those very
allies
that looks pretty bad right yeah it does
look really really bad only problem is
that video was not taken of that Kurdish
town that video is not from Syria at all
that video is not from this year that
video is not from that continent that
video was taken from a Kentucky gun show
in 2017 those images you're seeing
that's Kentucky and it's people shooting
a bunch of guns and firearms at a random
field in Kentucky
only right-wingers called this out they
said you know that this doesn't look
right
ABC finally acknowledged it they did
they acknowledged it in a big on-air
report on ABC News and primetime no no
no they sent out a statement they posted
a statement they said quote we've taken
down video that aired on World News
Tonight Sunday and Good Morning America
this morning that appeared to be from
the Syrian border immediately after
questions were raised about its accuracy
ABC News regrets the error it what do
you mean it appeared to be from the
Syrian border you don't know that you've
got video of guns being shot that's what
you got and after questions were raised
it's not after questions were raised we
know we know we have the video the video
is from a Kentucky gun show so hey we
ran a fake news report and we're not
actually going to apologize for it or
retract the report because we're fake
news this is what they do they run the
fake story on page one
they run the correction on page 375 they
run the fake story on television and
then they post the retraction in a tweet
maybe maybe we should question what the
mainstream media tell us about foreign
affairs about domestic policy maybe even
about the President of the United States
ironically I can't believe I'm saying
this I'm giving him so much credit the
most honest person in politics right now
I think is beta or orc certainly nobody
in the news it's not a news person it's
not not a Hollywood celebrity it's not a
Paula not a real politician
it's an out-of-work politician named
bado or work is bado O'Rourke
is saying a lot of stupid things he's
making a lot of untrue statements but
he's honest because he is actually
showing the logical conclusions of
leftist policies so he was called out he
raised some firestorm because he was too
honest during the LGBTQ townhall on CNN
during that townhall he was asked would
you take away tax-exempt status from
churches that don't go along with
leftist ideology and he said yeah
absolutely if you don't go along with
leftist ideology and and whatever the
new definition of marriage is today and
whatever the new version of gender
ideology is today then we're gonna take
away your tax exemption we're gonna try
to bankrupt you will make you face
consequences so this caught flak not
because people disagreed with him I mean
most of the candidates at that CNN
debate agreed with the statement it's
because he put it too honestly but a to
bluntly it was in too stark terms so
beta work was asked about this on MSNBC
MSNBC basically saying abate obeyed Oh
cut it out man don't let don't tell them
what we're really up to and beta or work
to his credit doubles down to be clear
you are free to believe anything that
you want to in this country to associate
with whom you please to practice your
faith as you best see fit but you are
not allowed to discriminate against
people in this country to violate their
civil rights or their human rights I
love the but look you're you're allowed
to practice your religion but and thence
that but makes them a Butthead but
you're not really allowed to you're not
allowed to discriminate what does that
word mean in the context of religion
you're not allowed to discriminate
I mean ideas discriminate if you hold
one idea you are necessarily
discriminating against other ideas if
you believe in one God you are
discriminating against other gods so if
you let's say you've got a church and
you don't worship Allah and you don't
invite people in who worship Allah
because you're a Methodist so you you
worship the Methodist conception of God
is that I guess that's discrimination
you're gonna be shut down let's use the
gender or the sex example
in the Catholic Church there are priests
there have always been priests there
have never been priestesses women can't
be priests they can be nuns they can do
a lot of things they can't be priests
well that's discrimination so is paid or
working to shut down the Catholic Church
yeah it sounds like he would he would
try to I don't I don't think he'd win
Catholic Church endure it a little bit
longer than then could be taken down by
a one-term congressman or more than a
one-term congressman but now an
ex-congressman I I don't I think the
church would probably went out I some
people are calling on bata or work to
change his tune I don't want him to
change us to and I'm glad he's telling
us what he really thinks he's telling us
with the left really things he's telling
us what the left thinks not just about
this issue of gender ideology he's
telling us what they think about
religion because here's the key here's
the key specific baito or ork says
people are free to practice their
religion within their churches once you
go outside the church though all bets
are off there's a lot of concern that a
policy like that even people have good
conscience to agree with you on the
underlying point that conservative black
churches mosques Islamic organizations
Orthodox Jewish communities a number of
religiously affiliated HBCUs they could
all lose their tax-exempt status under
such a plan to be specific the way that
you practice your religion or your faith
within that mosque or that temple or
synagogue or Church that is your
business and not the government's
business but when you are providing
services in the public sphere say higher
education or health care or adoption
services and you discriminate or deny
equal treatment under the law based on
someone's skin color or ethnicity or
gender or sexual orientation then we
have a problem
so baito our work has really really
confused thinking here he hasn't really
thought through these things at all but
I give him credit because the line is
that look the left always knocks on the
churches but they're usually pretty
quiet about the mosques so they'll
accuse Christians and all sorts of
terrible bigotry and awful terrible
things they usually lay off the Muslims
or you know frankly a little more
hardcore and
some of these issues bado goes for it he
says yeah
mosques historically black churches any
socially conservative institution we're
going after all of them now he says
you're free to practice your religion as
you want within your church that
contradicts what he just previously said
which is if the church is discriminating
then you can't practice it you know I
mean if you I oh if the church isn't
gonna officiate gay weddings same-sex
weddings
then we're they're gonna lose their tax
exemption well the same-sex weddings
take place inside the church
so he's contradicting himself there but
then he says again look if you whatever
you do inside the church is fine but
whatever you do inside the public sphere
that's not fine the church is the public
sphere the church is not private you
don't have most people don't have
private chapels in their homes and even
if they do you have to bring in people
from the outside because the church is
about community that is public but
according to bethe or work the
government controls everything that is
public and the private sphere is just
this tiny little thing this is in no way
what the Founding Fathers thought about
religion the founding fathers did not
believe that freedom of religion meant
you could go inside a building once a
week and think what you wanted to think
but the minute you left you didn't have
that freedom religious practice is not
just going to church every so often
religious practice is a 24/7 thing we
lose sight of that these days because
religion has declined dramatically in
America religious practice isn't just
from 10:00 a.m. to 11:00 a.m. on Sunday
it's all week long it is how you live
your life we have religious liberty to
allow people not to have a nice
alternative to brunch on Sunday we have
religious liberty because people want to
live their lives according to their
conscience --is and according to their
God the left doesn't understand that
bait or work doesn't understand that he
doesn't understand a lot of things but
at least he's honest about his thoughts
we've got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube we have got an incredible guest
coming up though Peter Benjamin a Peter
Benjamin is a man who lived with gender
confusion for much of his life he got
involved in cross-dressing for many
years he ultimately was told by doctors
that he had gender dysphoria was
transgender he went through the surgery
the cost of ten thousand pounds so
around $15,000 to the UK government it
didn't solve his problems in some ways
it made it worse seven years later he
decided to get out of that and D
transition it's a story you won't see in
the mainstream media but we will bring
it to you as the left embraces this
radical gender ideology du jour we will
show you the other side from people who
actually know something about it that's
gonna be after the break you got to go
to daily wire.com ten bucks a month
hundred dollars for an annual membership
you get me the Android slave and show
the ben shapiro show that mount will
show you get to ask questions in the
mailbag you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom which
the third episode just dropped yesterday
and it is terrific so go on and check it
out you get everything you get at the
leftist here's tumblr do not allow
yourself to drown during tonight's
democratic debate be sure to head over
there daily we're calm we'll be right
back with a lot more
my guest right now is Peter Benjamin you
know I don't do guests a lot on the show
but I just had to bring Peter on because
his story is so incredible and what he's
gone through is is so harrowing and his
story is not being told by the
mainstream media in fact it's being
completely covered up I spoke to Peter
yesterday when I was filling in on Ben's
radio show and unfortunately we got cut
off we can only speak for a short amount
of time so I wanted to bring him back on
my show today Peter is now 60 he served
in the British Army from the age of 16
to 20 and he went through the
transgender surgery in September of 2015
at a private hospital in London this was
after years of beginning the process of
transitioning and he is now in the
process of D transitioning out of that
Peter thank you so much for being here
and I'm Mike Koch good afternoon how EA
I'm doing very well I was so sorry that
we got it cut off yesterday on the radio
I I wanted to I I know my audience would
love to hear your story because they're
not seeing it in a lot of other places
just in in a nutshell I know it's it's
hard to sum up that many decades of life
how did you find yourself pulled into
this kind of gender ideology and what
made you go through with the surgery and
how did you get out of it I am trust
rest for many years which meant weekends
or not evening so put on women's clothes
and go out I was married but I started
in the 80s cross-dressing and this
covered on for many years and in 2011 my
wife died and I was still cross-dressing
and then there was this surge of people
changing gender and it was on social
media it was in the press it was online
on Google and I was reading all this
stuff and I was suffering with
depression anxiety I had suicidal
thoughts and I went to my GP
and I said to her I want to change
gender it came across you know I thought
some I need to change gender I was
living on my own I was also drinking
heavily drinking lots of alcohol and I
made that decision to change gender so
she went away and told me to go and live
the real life test for a month which I
did and then I was sent to a local
registrar psychiatrist who cut a long
story short said I had no underlying
mental health problems well I did my
wife hadn't long died I was on hormone
medication and her meds I was on
antidepressants I was on all sorts of
medication and I was drinking heavily so
I had underlying medical problems
anxiety being one of them and depression
he referred me on to the gender identity
clinic in London but I went I couldn't
wait because the alcohol an alcoholic
can't wait and they become addictive
I've got an addictive personality so I
paid for private time consultation and
it cost me a lot of money then I was
referred under the NHS the gender
identity clinic I saw the same doctor
I'd saw privately twice and then I saw
another doctor and he said I'm referring
you forward to surgery but in between I
had been to a transgender I was having
transgender counseling for a local
support group and my counselor never
once told me I'm doing the wrong thing
as a matter of fact he said you're doing
the right thing you're going down the
road you're doing the right thing this
transgender support group
it's money from the gut from the lottery
funding it gets money from the police
and crime Commissioner to run now a lot
of people there have underlying mental
health conditions or mental health
conditions but they're still encouraged
to go forward for surgery I then lived
as well I had my surgery in 2015 I saw
my surgeon I was referred for surgery
and I had to go on to a private waiting
list because young HS waiting list was
full up and if they breach they would
have been fined a lot of money I saw my
surgeon once explained what the
operation was going to be and then I was
booked in for December the 15
2015 I went I went for my surgery
afterwards I lived in a flat on my own I
wasn't I wasn't happy about it
I didn't feel happy about having my
surgery but I carried on my life now
part of my I say why I had to surgery
part of it was but I thought I could
mingle him with other women go out to
ladies that do lunch go out you know
socially and stuff like that
that never happened that that did not
happen my I didn't have a circle of
friends and female friends it just
didn't happen and I live I lived a
lonely life on my own I moved to where I
lived in the first place but again that
circle of friends that I had before as a
before my surgery they didn't want to
know me and I was living a life on my
own so I do want to enjoy these days
walking swimming cycling stuff like that
in so this was 2015 I moved where I live
now in 2017 in on Good Friday this year
I met a lady when I was out in my local
shopping center I was out evangelizing
telling people about Jesus and she came
up to me and said who is Pete I said
that used to be me now I was going to
church but I barely knew this lady and
she said you know God doesn't want you
to be Victoria and I said yes he's been
telling me the same but I wasn't
listening I just wasn't listening and I
knew God had been telling me this
clearly so I came home sat down thought
about it I thought she's right I've got
I can't disobey God's Word voice anymore
so I packed everything away I literally
packed all my female clothes away but I
had no men's clothes so I had to go out
to a charity shops and buy what I needed
and everything else and I'd know men's
shoes I had trainers so well then I
gradually built up my male wardrobes I
had to go into work to tell them that
I'd be transitioned back to male and
this is my name some went all through
that but
so had changed churches since I saw that
lady and there was two ladies at my new
church who I barely knew who said that
they'd been praying for me to become to
come back to be Pete my past also said
someone in this church has got wolves on
their back he was speaking to me it was
like a bolt in my heart so I went it did
all that but I also found that I went to
House of Prayer nightma local area in
another area I also found out this
church and House of Prayer been praying
for me as well said all these people
praying for me and I didn't know and it
was really powerful and I came to church
his pay and I was but all the time I was
as Victoria I was loved as Pete I am
loved by my church and it's fantastic
and I just feel so much better now it's
like a big weight has been lifted off me
it's gone it's completely gone I said
the medication is is had side effects on
me from people not female hormones but
I'm not an anti depressants anymore I'm
not an anxiety tablets anymore they've
all gone completely gone and but I was
told I need to go back to the gender
identity clinic to sort out the
dysphoria
there is no dysphoria my mind has been
renewed I've it's completely gone it's
completely vanished
yeah that's an incredible journey I mean
I'm so sorry to hear all the things you
you had to go through and I'm very glad
to hear that that it seems to seems to
have worked out in the end did in in
terms of that that moment that you came
back I mean I guess there are two
moments I want to ask you about the
moment where you have the surgery and
you kind of go all the way through to
appear like a woman and to identify then
as a woman yes did it did it meet your
expectations in terms of how you felt in
your own body obviously it didn't meet
your social expectations but did it did
you feel like a woman after the surgery
or no no I didn't like women oh oh I
just felt like I
always had done as Pete except I hadn't
had my male genitalia but I did not feel
like a woman one bit as a matter of fact
it caused more problems you said now I
can walk out my front door and do what
wants to do but then it would take me an
hour maybe half an hour to get out that
door I was so anxious so nervous going
to face the simple thing like going to
the shops I could not do it and it just
ends up when I was in all these tablets
as well for the anxiety but no I didn't
feel like a woman at all I was I felt
like you know there was no difference in
me I just it was a chore at the entered
the date and put the globe's on but it
it it was a routine that I had but it
was more of a chore there was no there
was no feelings whatsoever and my doctor
said to me
when I went and told her of reverted my
gender change back to man she said it
was a sexual thing it was lust I said
yes it was it was sexual it was lust and
she was right she she was yeah she hit a
nail on the head
that did it I think what what some
people would say the people who were
still pushing this transgender surgery
and transgender movement for everybody
is they would say well you know this is
just evidence that society needs to be
better at the considering people who
have had this gender surgery tube it
really be the gender that they are now
identifying as do you think that's the
assure do you think the issue is really
deeper down that deep down you knew that
you were Pete and you weren't really
Victoria and that's why you feel better
about it no it wasn't that I before the
surgery I felt like Victoria I I would I
felt about even after yeah I felt as a
woman when I used to trust dress I felt
as a woman but how does a woman and feel
how how I can't explain how a woman
feels Bryan explain that because my DNA
hasn't been changed I've always been a
man
inside but how does a woman fail I
couldn't feel that sort of thing inside
yeah it's nice putting on the nice
dresses and looking nice and smart and I
did have some nice clothes but how does
a woman fail I don't know
cuz I wasn't born a woman so right right
I mean this what what I mean I'm so glad
that you have have now found peace in
all of the having had to go through hell
basically and come back out the other
side although now we're mean when we're
talking about these gender identity
issues it seems to me we know basically
nothing about it and people are now
pushing this ideology on not just adult
men and encouraging them to get the
surgery and encouraging them to identify
as the opposite sex there they're also
now pushing this on children I mean
children is in the single digits
what where does this come from and and
do you have any any warning any message
for for the doctors and the parents and
the children who might be going through
this yes
a lot of warnings well I don't know
where the children where the children
idea came from but the internet doesn't
help and the children are watching
programs like if I go on my phone and
I've got an app for my television
programs the first thing I see is some
like RuPaul's RuPaul's Drag Race on
their children watching programs like
that
there's loads of programs from people
--is-- television about transgender and
children are watching it and they get
glamorized by it and children are doing
harm to themselves the air ram that
medication that they're on they're gonna
have when the girls get older they'll
have to have hysterectomies when they
become 18 or whatever boys will have to
will be impudent they won't be able to
maintain an erection there's all the
problems of blood clots cardiac problems
I'm not doctor but this is liver
problems kidney problems there's going
to be all sorts of problems as they come
I'll grow older why can't they just let
children be who they are and grow up
yeah they go in the I went in the
dressing up box and I put on
my old dad's Army uniforms I don't go
around wearing army uniform all the time
no but why can't they let children grow
up and parents should watch out and what
they're letting their children watch
it's their world wide web I was taken in
by what I saw and on the websites on Pro
um things like that I wasn't him I was
ill at the time and I was taken in by
all this and this is what's happening to
children and other transgender people it
split my marriage up my children were
affected by it because of what I did I
was really selfish for what I did and I
lived to regret it now so well it sounds
I mean obviously you know people people
have all sorts of regrets it sounds
though like you've you've come to a
place that is one of peace and being a
little more accepting of who you are and
in your identity hi I'm Mike I'm so much
at peace now with myself I feel so much
better in myself it's just amazing it's
just amazing what's happened well it's
amazing it's really it's an amazing
story and as sorry as I am to hear that
yet you had to suffer so much along the
way physically and emotionally there is
say there is I suppose a hope that your
suffering could show people and give
people a warning and shed some light on
this issue which is really being twisted
and and you really only say one side
that in the mainstream media it's having
real effects not just on adults but on
on children Peter thank you so much I
let you go I've taken up much of your
time already thank you so much and best
of luck and god bless my friend please
thank you Michael all right bye
Peter Benjamin incredible incredible
story and there you know on the Candice
Owens show she just interviewed Walt
hire who is another guy who identified
as the opposite sex for about the same
period of time I think about eight years
and regretted it and it actually I
believe it made his his depression and
anxiety suicidal thoughts worse
now he's out of it and he feels much
more at peace that's the other side of
the story that you won't hear in the
mainstream media because that's the
difference between truth and fake news
we got a lot more to get to we'll have
to do it tomorrow in the meantime I am
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles Oh see them
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey it's Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Klavan show LeBron James may be
the best thrower of balls through hoops
since balls were hoop but he won't stand
up for freedom neither will the NBA the
NFL ESPN Disney or the Democrats or the
press will just have to do it ourselves
on the Andrew Clavin show
I'm Andrew clay
[Music]